ich habe auf den bock waren schauen wir
auf kinder lieder die ich zumindest noch
kenne die wir alle singen vielleicht
auch immer noch unseren kindern
vorsingen das zdf das warnt aber jetzt
vor einem wie ich finde auf ersten blick
recht harmlosen
wir hören einfach mal rein
die affen rasen durch den wald deine
macht den andern galt die ganze affen
gute laune ist
natürlich was könnte sein tierschützer
die vielleicht irgendwie ja weil die
coca cola offen auf den kopf fällt auch
im laufe des liedes nur das natürlich
schon das schon hart also warm sein aber
das ist jetzt überlegen das zdf waren
jedenfalls ist könnte rassismus in die
kinderzimmer transportieren und das wird
mit einem posting auf dem instagram
kanal around the world erklärt dass eben
vom öffentlich rechtlichen sender
zdfkultur betrieben wird und dort wird
gewarnt das fröhliche lied wer hat die
kokosnuss geklaut deutet rassistische
stereotype gegen bei kann das ist
wirklich hier recht
kompliziert auch erklärt dass bei
projizierte kolonialistische klischee
von kriminellen und triebgesteuerten
affen also hier wird die frage gestellt
rassismus im kinderzimmer tragen wir mit
so einem lied rassismus ins kinderzimmer
ich habe es ehrlicherweise nicht
verstanden das müssen wir noch einmal
erklären in ihrem studio von ralf
schuler weil die erklärung vom zdf die
erhält mich jetzt noch nicht davon ab
das lied zu singen was genau ist das
problem an diesem song mit der kokosnuss
als parlaments reporter über opel zu
sprechen kommt auch nicht jeden tag vor
der eigentliche skandal ist die
skandalisierung die da vorgenommen wird
denn es ist ganz klar was die kollegen
dort wollen die taz hat es ja schon
aufgeschrieben die kollegen sind der
ansicht weil man vor über affen spricht
erinnere man sich an schwarze menschen
und wolle sie herabwürdigen also wer auf
den gedanken kommt bei einem lied was
sich über lustige affen die mit einer
kokosnuss durch den wald tollen an
schwarze denkt da ist eigentlich
tatsächlich im denken irgendetwas schief
gelaufen wir kennen das aus
fußballstadien
farbige spieler manchmal mit affenlauten
bedacht werden da liegt tatsächlich
etwas vor was mir rassismus oder anders
nennen können von affen auf schwarze zu
schließen ist eigentlich der eigentliche
skandal das hat die taz auch ganz gut
aufgeschrieben und das geht eigentlich
so gar nicht mal abgesehen davon ist
diese ewige suche dieses fahnden nach
irgendeiner diskriminierung ist schon
zum teil wirklich krankhaft die umwelt
die tierschutzorganisation peta hat dazu
aufgerufen keine spezies ist ischen
äußerungen zu verwenden fragt sich der
normalbürger was ist das erst einmal
bürgerfragen gemeint sind wendungen wie
da wird der hund in der pfanne verrückt
weil da wird der hund herabgesetzt und
zu einem objekt in der pfanne möchte
eigentlich auch kein hund landen oder
die die katzen tollen um das haus man
sollte
solche sachen also auch das soll man
eigentlich fällig sein man muss sich
einfach klarmachen da sind leute
unterwegs die denken das leben ist
irgendwie stubenrein und man muss alles
verbannen was in irgendeiner weise
metaphorisch gemeint sein würde also
einfach mal die kirche im dorf lassen
gang runterschalten und sagt man das
noch sagen kirche im dorf ist also könne
möglicherweise sie wissen und
katholischen kirche auch nicht mehr
alles so rund läuft ja und die orthodoxe
ist auch außen raus also in die hacken
lassen wir die häuser im dorf vorsicht
vorsicht vor und muss ich musste an
unsere hunde zu hause die nicht in der
pfanne verrückt werden und die frist
niemals die fahren keine gran erklärt
von heute auch nicht wenn wir das uns
weil über die lippen rutscht dann greif
für deinen besuch hier bei uns um
aufklärung